welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Voss and be honest did you really get
everything that went down in that
glorious finale of Loki no yes it was an
amazing finale it was beautiful we were
crying but there was a lot of questions
remaining that even the producers don't
really have answers for and it's not
their fault it's because the MCU
historically has been allergic to
anything resembling finality because
this franchise can never end and that is
what makes Loki sticking this Landing as
well as it did so miraculous in this
video we're going to talk about the
fates of these other characters notably
Victor timley I'm talking about Victor
timley on that Loom observation deck
after the shutters closed Victor timley
we never saw in the rest of this episode
aside from his sacred timeline self
who's still making candles so what
happened to this nerd is he dead is he
spaghetti did his mind go back into that
young Candle Maker or is he working in
the TVA mail room I actually have an
answer of what happened to Victor timley
and yes there is a single shot in this
finale that tells us where he is okay
this whole season hinges around the
crisis in which the temporal Loom fails
and the radiation destroys the TVA in
the finale Loki upon learning to control
his time slipping Loops back countless
times upon this failure but Victor
timley always spaghet ofies even if
Victor didn't head out onto that core
that Loom would fail and spaghettify
everyone on the observation deck anyway
so when Loki becomes the god of stories
and turns that dead timeline into the
yeer time tree what happens to Victor
and everyone else on that deck we see
what happens to everyone else in the
final minutes of the episode but
Victor's adult form is nowhere to be
seen the last time we see him is when
those shutter doors are closed and
everyone is just kind of looking out in
that direction
hopefully all the episode really gives
us is this little moment with Victor
back as a boy in 1868 Chicago making
candles turning to see his open window
but no book flies in but this kid is not
the Victor timley we've been following
this kid is what Victor timley would
have become had he not met Rona RN
Slayer in episode three we saw this boy
making candles when he received the
handbook from RN Slayer and that was
1868 sacred timeline according to the
lower third and then later after he had
gotten that book 1893 Chicago that was a
branch timeline so that boy back making
candles never becoming a grifter with
Advanced Tech would have been how the
sacred timeline carried itself out that
kid was never supposed to get involved
in TV shananigans meanwhile grifter
adult Victor timley was always part of a
branch timeline it's kind of like the
Loki we've been following throughout the
series Loki l130 he is a variant the
Loki who branched off from the secret
timeline after the Tess slid to his feet
in the events of Avengers endgame the
normal Loki still progress forward in
history on the sacred timeline through
the events of the infinity Saga Thor the
Dark World Thor Ragnarok and then died
when Thanos broke his neck and infinity
War so young candlemaker Victor timley
similarly had a normal sacred timeline
life where no book came in through his
window and he kept making candles adult
grifter Victor timley was a variant on
his own path in the TVA and after God of
stories Loki closes those blast stories
we do see Victor watching alongside the
others in the darkness and then we never
see him again now we had thought at one
point in this series that Victor timley
might become the he who remains in the
Citadel that may be he who remains
origin story was in 1868 Chicago but but
no that is not the case Victor was one
of he remains variants and he remain
says in the finale that his whole plan
this season was to use Miss minutes and
ren Slayer to activate his variant at
first it seemed to replace him but no it
was really to put Victor on a path to
meet OB and Loki and then to up Loki's
time slipping skills so that Loki could
loop back to him in the Citadel and they
could resume their conversations without
happy to deal with Sylvie so he remains
as we've known him still has his origins
in the 31st Century as a scientist now
the fact that this 1868 boy grows up to
look exactly like Jonathan major is a
bit confusing yes but I will direct you
to my theory that he remains another
Kings extracted baby Nathaniel
richards's from across the time stream
and stored them throughout history as
sleeper cells waiting to be activated
for various purposes either way it is
clear that Victor Tim ley's fate is not
to become he remains in the Citadel
something else happened to him there's
never a wrong time to add away to ease
anxiety in your life which means right
now is the perfect time to pick up a
bond charge infrared sauna blanket bonch
charge is a holistic Wellness brand with
a huge range of evidence-based products
to optimize your life a bazillion ways
whether you want to sleep better have
more energy or just de-stress which is
where the infrared sauna blanket comes
in Bon charges sauna blanket raises your
heart rate so you burn calories while
you relax to help your body release
endorphins and leave you feeling relaxed
and euphoric it's super easy to set up
it Heats quickly and so now you can get
the same relaxing benefits you would get
from a SAA while reading a book for 40
minutes on your your couch Bon charge's
infrared sauna blanket has free shipping
worldwide and a 30-day free trial so you
can test it out risk-free go to bonch
charge.com and save 25% until the end of
December 2023 that's a saving of $175 on
your sauna blanket limited time only
while stocks last your discount code
will be automatically applied on your
order so what did happen to Victor
timely then Victor probably did not die
by spaghettify God of stories Loki
averted that fate for all of them Victor
timley could have been reinserted into
1893 Chicago that Wisconsin Workshop
that he was extracted from maybe his
memory wiped that is a possibility and
while these variants inside of the TVA
have undergone memory wipes protocol 42
we don't know if they know how to do
that to other people like Victor timley
if they were to reinsert them into the
timeline we just don't have precedents
of the TVA ever reinserting an extracted
variant to the timeline most of the time
they get extracted and their Branch
timeline got pruned while their
doppelganger variant lives on in the
sacred timeline that's what we saw with
Mobius looking at himself now Victor
timel could have gotten pruned to the
void but I don't think B15 and the
current staff of the TVA would do that
to him why because he is too useful to
the TVA he's gone through too much with
them and we know from Obie's second
edition of the TVA guide book that he is
okay co-editing it to Victor Victor is
still part of their history and part of
their organization so I think the
likeliest answer is Victor timley works
at the TVA now as the co-head of the
repairs and advancements Department as
an engineer who shares a workspace with
ob and there is a clue that points to
this in the overhead shot of OB unboxing
the second edition handbooks notice this
workspace the desk is now clean with
only a typewriter in the center and
tools on either side neatly laid out
compare that to the messy overwhelmed
workspace that Obi worked behind
throughout the season I think Victor
timley must share this desk and helped
OB declutter it in a way he is working
in the TVA mail room he's sorting memos
from those pneumatic tubes he's handling
triage and he's letting OB have a break
every now and then that's why we were
able to see OB with Casey up in a Chron
monitor Bay because someone else El must
have been monitoring the desk down below
and I pointed out in yesterday's video
that pages of that new TVA handbook are
blank maybe that's intentional maybe not
but it could be that Obie and Victor are
about to sit down and fill these blank
pages with all their shared knowledge
their designs their blueprints for how
they think things should work so what
happened to Victor timley I think the
most rational explanation is that he is
still working in this new wonderful TVA
as part of ob's engineering team to make
the TVA a better place and the epilog
maybe just didn't show him because it
could just raise too many questions to
to see a Kang variant continue inside of
the TVA now to quickly break down what
happened to the other characters Obi KY
mp15 obviously still working for this
new version of the TVA maintaining
timelines rather than pruning them Miss
minutes is of course rebooted to her
original programming at any point she
could kill them X5 we did not see
walking around the TV but he did appear
on the cover of mob' jet ski Magazine
with his actor headshot so supposedly
he's living his dream life on the secret
timeline as actor Brad wolf movus seemed
like he was head of for retirement but
upon witnessing himself as a father of
two on the timeline in clev he seemed to
have everything he needed just by
watching that executive producer Kevin
Wright told Screen Rant that Mobius has
overcome an obstacle but where Mobius
goes from here is New Territory so it's
pretty much open-ended for Mobius for
Sylvie headwriter Eric Martin told
Esquire Sylvia is interesting because of
all the stuff with McDonald's and her
living that quiet life it feels very Gap
year-ish I'm not quite ready to grow up
and do the thing and she was pulled out
of that now the work begins I'm not sure
where she goes from here but I don't
think she's going to live just a quiet
life maybe she would I don't know but
she's going to make a very active
decision about what she's going to do
whatever that is she's making that
choice it isn't just like oh I'm going
to feel things out she's going to go in
a direction sounds like they just didn't
write it now for Ren Slayer Eric Martin
said this I'll let people Muse about
what that can mean she's up in the air
there are things that can happen with
her if you look to the comics there are
some fun inferences that can be drawn
from the pyramid and you know who knows
does elith kill her or do they strike up
a friendship maybe elith rerer I don't
know hey at least he gives us the
pyramids to look at because those
pyramids and that Sphinx behind her were
in the void in season 1 and I'm pretty
sure that Sphinx has the face of
Jonathan major when we first met pharoh
Ramat tutut in Fantastic 4 number 19 in
1963 he was using the Sphinx as a mobile
time machine I've always believed that
he remains needed Rin Slayer in order to
tame elith so yeah she could have a
history with this thing the Disney plus
closed captions describe the audio over
Ren Slayer as quote metal clanking that
sound could be the sound of a hatch
opening or RN Slayer could take that
Sphinx ship and her new pet elith and
travel through time to do whatever she
wants I just don't think 1868 Victor
timely is the only young Kang variant
hidden throughout history so while we
have a good guess as to what happened to
one Victor timely the full story is
still being written hey the best way to
support new Rockstar is to grab some
merch at nerd rot. shop follow me on all
social platforms at eaos And subscribe
to all three channels in the new
rockstars Network thanks for watching
I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye